I think the national media coverage of
Venezuela increases it seems as if their
national media coverage of their own
country is actually decreasing at the
time we were preparing this video we had
a look at the website of Telesur one of
their largest state-owned television
networks on the main page they had 29
headlines and just six of them were
talking about their own country despite
what this looks like on the face of
things though this couldn't actually
resemble any better what is actually
happening in Venezuela today there is no
one who denies that the South American
country is going through one of the
worst humanitarian crises that the
entire continent have ever seen
according to a study run by three
universities from this country the
average Venezuelan weighs between nine
and ten kilos less than two years ago
when these food shortages began now the
big question is how much blame should be
apportioned to the Venezuelan president
Nicolas Maduro and this is where people
have rather different opinions
[Music]
according to many political analysts
Venezuela is not a democratic nation
anymore things like the president's
attempt to dissolve the Parliament or
jailing politicians from the opposition
have triggered diplomatic crises at the
highest level in the medieval
illimitable rapido retires their
ambassador in Venezuela with the support
of their Parliament nonetheless there
are others who still play in Venezuela
is a democracy they even say Nicolas
Maduro the president is defending
himself from a huge car so the question
is here who is right can we say the
Venezuela is a dictatorship or is this
something of an exaggeration today we're
going to answer this question but before
we do let's check out the story of
Nicolas Maduro mendes government which
is preparing a coup d'etat
according to Madeira the Venezuelan
crisis can be summarized as a conspiracy
by the United States and our allies to
destroy the Bolivarian revolution and
the so called 21st century socialism
they lead imperialists okay but as
imperialist elite despises our people
and have the goal of destroying our
lifestyle our democracy our independence
and our homeland they have decided to
trigger plans to destabilize the
Venezuelan Society oh yes listen I know
what you're probably thinking but let's
just imagine for a quick moment that
that theory actually makes some kind of
sense in this case the imperialist
elites are not only trying to dismantle
the Venezuelan economy but also their
government and this is what explains
Nicolas Maduro sphere of the coop but
hold on for just a moment because before
we continue we should explain what the
coup actually means well a coup d'etat
is defined as the taking of power in a
sudden and violent action carried out by
a powerful group like the army and
surprise surprise the Venezuelan Army is
absolutely loyal to Nicolas Maduro
this is the father of the Bolivarian
revolution Hugo Chavez used to be a
member of the military unlike other
countries like the UK where it is
forbidden by law for soldiers to run for
office in Venezuela there are several
ministers that come from the Armed
Forces here we have left tenant Melendez
Rivas the president's chief of staff or
the general Marko Rivas the minister of
food actually one third of Maduro
government comes from the military
[Music]
this being said who could successfully
conduct a coup in Venezuela
according to Maduro well as you might've
guessed he suggests this would be his
political opponents there's only one
problem with this theory though not one
of them have any relationship whatsoever
with the military people like Enric a
Capri notes or Leopoldo Lopez or any of
the other opposition leaders are
professional politicians or former
businessman and they have no military
groups supporting them despite all of
this the government keeps saying that
all these politicians are the real
instigators all of the countries treat
father
[Music]
if you can imagine that in a country
where people need a full day's wages to
get a bag of onion it's absolutely
normal that people would want to
organize demonstrations oh and add to
this the fact that Caracas is the most
violent city in all of Latin America and
you'll probably understand why most of
the protest ends up like this
[Music]
nonetheless according to the government
of Venezuela the clashes between the
police and the protesters and noting
that the outcome of bourgeoisie
propaganda this is why in September of
three months before having parliamentary
elections the Venezuelan police arrested
Leopoldo Lopez one of the opposition
leaders the prosecutor claimed that if
man was inciting people into violence
with these kind of statements made on
Twitter you have the guts to take me to
prison are you waiting for orders from
Havana I'm telling you the truth is on
our side
[Music]
but the turning point would come later
in December of 2015 at this time
Venezuela has parliamentary elections
and as you can imagine the opposition
party is unified in the so-called table
of democratic unity aka the MU D beat
Maduro party by over 2 million votes the
president's reaction was actually what
you'd expect from every Democratic
leader at cornell 7 it have recognized
this outcome even if we don't like it
that we accept it and we say that
democracy and the Constitution are the
real winners here but the hold on for
just a moment because this is when the
problem starts this brand-new
anti-government Parliament started
trying to impeach the president and this
is when all of a sudden Maduro and his
ministers made a radical shift only what
the father like oklahoma economic war
had influence of a big share of our
population and this turned the public
opinion during this time Nicolas Maduro
tried to dissolve Parliament according
to his government some of those MPs had
been elected by cheating in the
electoral process but not even the
Supreme Court has Venezuela accepted
this version this is why on May the 1st
Maduro made his final decision Jockamo
political p2y and originario
calling up the constitutional power to
get the peace this republic needs to
beat the fascist coup and let the people
bring the harmony and the actual
national dialogue in other words Madeira
wants a new Parliament to write a brand
new constitution which would give him
unlimited power and this would be the
ultimate step for creating a
dictatorship and as you might well now
wonder is this going to be through an
election
[Music]
well theoretically yes but the truth is
that since 2015 there are lots of
opposition leaders behind bars and so
well what about the media Medora
supporters say that Venezuela has
freedom of speech but is this really
true well that's a look at that is their
freedom of speech in Venezuela according
to the current Venezuelan Constitution
freedom of speech is a fundamental right
and yes there are many newspapers who
oppose the new government but guess what
the problem these newspapers have is
well they don't actually have any paper
on which to print their news
[Music]
just like that in Venezuela paper is a
monopoly regulated by the state and this
is why a media outlet like El Nacional
which is contrary to Maduro has to
reduce their circulation and even the
number of pages in their newspaper other
dailies have had to become weeklies
because they couldn't print so many
papers and now you might be wondering
well what about the internet I mean
who's in reads print papers anymore well
unfortunately Maduro and his governments
have an absolute power to block any
website at the other hand of the site of
this league this is a site where you
could put the links at any page and it
makes it shorter so you can tweet it
easily
does it sound counter-revolutionary to
you well check this out we shortcuts are
banned in Venezuela as you can imagine
if bitly is forbidden other critical
websites like CNN dollars a day or info
BAE or so bans
if you live in Venezuela and you want to
visit these websites you must do it
through a proxy just like in China and
of course don't forget that there have
been more than 40 journalists threatened
by the government's allies or even worse
six Twitter users are in jail in
Venezuela for giving their political
opinions yep you have that right they
are not being judged or fined they are
in prison but hold on for just a minute
because all of this is nothing compared
to what's happening in television you
could have Scully
communication the decades Caracas was
the Hollywood of South American soap
operas Venezuela was famous for having
lots of private TV stations and of
course some of them were contrary to
murderers governments the Venezuelan
Constitution provides the freedom of
speech on TV but on the other hand the
law forces them to broadcast all of the
president's speeches and we're not
talking about one show a year
Maduro appears on TV several times a
week and the tvs have to make a break
matter their schedule and broadcast the
presidential speech sometimes these
speeches can last for hours and add to
this other stories like this one noble
vision a Venezuelan TV broadcaster is
sold to a new owner who promises a new
more moderate ideology the for Maduro is
the president during the time the Hugo
she says Globovision
was a die-hard anti-government TV
station but all of a sudden it was sold
in 2013 and new owners had placed ties
with the president so the first thing
they did were in later control of the
company was to fire half of the staff
and then no surprise surprise
Globovision became a centrist station
but making a mistake this is merely one
example today there is almost no needier
in Venezuela that is critical of the
government so the question I would now
like to ask you is this what exactly is
the difference between Nicolas Maduro
and any other dictator can anybody claim
Venezuela is still really a democracy
well we'd love to know what you think
and you can let us know in the comment
section below
meanwhile you should definitely check
out this video we made talking all about
how the crisis in Venezuela got started
[Music]
also don't forget to visit our friends
from the region to the media podcast who
gave us the voice on this video that is
not mine and of course don't forget that
we publish brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and on the screen now and
you won't miss any video and also if you
like this video please do give it a
thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time and if you'd like to hear more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider the podcast that covers
politics but we don't do the thinking
for you available on your favorite
podcast see you there
[Music]